Benvenuti suita Stories c'è una novità
oggi vi diremo un'altra novità e voi
penserete ma come già Nell'altro video
ci avete già dato una novità e adesso ce
n'è ancora un'altra e vi racconteremo
tutta la storia più guardate il video
fino alla fine perché vi diremo un'altra
cosa molto importante Ma ora passiamo
subito alle presentazioni perché come
avete visto dal titolo Abbiamo adottato
un'altra gattina e ora ve la facciamo
subito conoscere 3 2 1 t Eccola qua è
bellissima è una gatina piccolissima e
arancione e adesso vi raccontiamo tutta
la sua storia è
dolcissima amore bellissimo Guarda
piccolina Lì c'è tutta la Stories Family
che vuole
conoscerti Allora vi starete chiedendo
ma come Anita avete già preso una
gattina da poco come mai avete preso
un'altra gattina Allora innanzitutto vi
facciamo vedere quanto è cresciuta la
gattina che abbiamo preso se non avete
visto il video andate poi a vederlo
perché vi raccontiamo tutto e cioè
perché l'abbiamo presa come è arrivata a
casa e vi chiediamo anche del nome
Andate a vedere quel video una volta che
finite di vedere questo video e guardate
un po' quanto è cresciuta Eccolo lì che
giocano è cresciuta tantissimo Guardate
quanto è grande perché abbiamo preso
un'altra gattina Allora in realtà non
era programmata questa cosa ma questa
povera gattina è stata trovata in
campagna e la mamma non la voleva più l'
allontanata Quindi ho deciso di fare da
babysitter per qualche giorno a questa
gattina per poi darla in adozione solo
che nei giorni in cui ho fatto da
babysister mi sono affezionata
tantissimo perché lei stava sempre con
me dormiva con me insomma mi sono
affezionata e le voglio un sacco di bene
e abbiamo deciso di tenerla Quindi ora
la Stories Family è ancora più grande
perché abbiamo il altro Merlino poi
abbiamo Circe e poi abbiamo la gattina
bianca e arancione e la nuova gattina
arancione Guardate che carina e vi
starete anche chiedendo qual è il nome
della gattina nuova ancora non lo
sappiamo e anche qua dobbiamo chiedere
il vostro consiglio consigliateci il
nome giù nei commenti ma ora facciamo
una cosa super divertente cioè facciamo
qualche Challenge con le nuove gattine
vedi vediamo come se la cavono E chi
vince tra loro due in realtà all'inizio
noi pensavamo che fosse un maschio
perché la maggior parte dei gatti rossi
Sono maschi però poi abbiamo scoperto
che è molto probabilmente una
femminuccia cioè la veterinaria c ha
detto sì è quasi sicuramente una
femminuccia quindi consigliateci i nomi
da femmina gattina femmina Rossa nei
commenti Ovviamente è un nome che stia
bene anche con l'altra gattina bianca e
rossa ma prima vi devo dire una cosa
tantissima è appena uscito per il
preordine il mio nuovissimo libro La
città stregata gli investigatori del
mistero è una nuovissima storia in cui
c'è un mistero da risolvere e voi vi
trasformerete in degli investigatori del
mistero come me e vitale perché i
protagonisti di questa nuova storia
siamo io e vitale riuscirete a risolvere
il mistero prima di arrivare alla fine
del libro in più dentro al libro c'è un
alfabeto segreto in cui possiamo
condividere dei messaggi segreti assieme
e ordinatelo subito per ricevere una
sorpresa assieme al libro vi lascio il
link in descrizione Mi raccomando
preordino subito per entrare a far parte
della squadra degli investigatori del
mistero la Challenge di velocità vediamo
chi è più veloce fra loro due pronti per
la gara 3 2 1
via Ma la piccolina non è neanche
partita per la gara si è distratta ha
vinto la sorellina più grande ma
proviamo un altro round con continua a
[Musica]
saltare 3 2 1 via e la piccolino in
testa l'ha preso prima lei ha vinto
questo secondo
round la più grande è rimasta
indietro ha vinto la piccolina la gara
di velocità che Ed ecco che arriva per
ultima è in ritardo anche la più grande
ma già persso la Challenge Merlino che
cosa ne pensa c'ho
sonno secondo round vediamo chi è più
veloce Questa volta la gattina grande in
testa si sta avvicinando sempre di più
Ehi no si sono distrat Ehi ma questa è
una gara Ve lo ricordate o
no
presto no non se lo ricordo sono
distratte e la seconda gara l'ha vinta
la sorellina più grande
ha deciso di giocare con la sua
coda prossima Challenge Vediamo chi
riesce per prima a prendere la pallina
vediamo
Ehi ma che state facendo là sopra c'è la
pallina qua Guardate 3 2 1
Uh
e l'ha presa la più grande per
prima La piccoletta invece un po'
confusa lì che gira intorno a
Merlino
che
carina ed ecco che l'ha presa anche lei
la pallina e gioca
tantissimo tutte e due via secondo round
lanciamo la pallina e vediamo chi la
prende prima in questo secondo round
e l'ha presa Prima la sorellina più
grande e invece quella piccola sta
odorando le scarpe di Vitale Eh che
puzza puza e mi metto qui al sole mi
abbronzo un po' ultima Challenge Chi è
la sorellina più coccolosa e lei è molto
coccolosa vuole sempre un po' di affetto
vero piccolina è molto coccolosa lei
anche se adesso Adesso vuole giocare
molto sveglia perché vuole giocare ma in
genere dorme sempre qua sulla mia spalla
e vediamo la sorellina più grande invece
adesso è super attiva perché è più
grande e vuole sempre sempre sempre
giocare sempre sempre super iper Attiva
la Challenge per più coccolosa La vince
la
[Musica]
piccolina
K
[Musica]
scriveteci nei commenti i consigli dei
nomi della gattina andate poi a vedere
l'altro video in cui Vi presentiamo la
sorella più grande e mi raccomando
preordinate subito il mio nuovo libro La
città stregata vi lascio il link in
descrizione e ora vi lascio quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quell che
preferite e buona visione C Ciao